- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is explore how experimental
probability should get
closer and closer to
theoretical probability
as we conduct more and more experiments
or as we conduct more and more trials.
This is often referred to
as The Law of Large Numbers.
If we only have a few
experiments, it's very possible
that our experimental probability could be
different than our theoretical probability
or even very different.
But as we have many many
more experiments, thousands,
millions, billions of
experiments, the probability
that the experimental and
the theoretical probabilities
are very different,
goes down dramatically.
But let's get an intuitive sense for it.
This right over here is a simulation
created by Macmillan USA.
I'll provide the link as an annotation.
And what it does is it
allows us to simulate
many coin flips and figure out
the proportion that are heads.
So right over here, we can
decide if we want our coin
to be fair or not.
Right now, it says that we have a
50% probability of getting heads.
We can make it unfair by changing this
but I'll stick with the 50% probability.
If we wanna show that on this graph here,
we can plot it.
And what this says is at a time,
how many tosses do we wanna take.
So let's say, let's just
start with 10 tosses.
So what this is going to
do is take 10 simulated
flips of coins with each one having
a 50% chance of being heads.
And then as we flip, we're gonna see
our total proportion that are heads.
So let's just talk through this together.
So starting to toss.
And so what's going on
here after 10 flips?
So as you see, the first
flip actually came out heads
and if you wanted to, say what's your
experimental probability
after that one flip,
you'd say well, with only one experiment,
I got one heads so it
looks like 100% were heads.
But in the second flip, it
looks like it was a tails.
Because now the proportion that was heads
after two flips was 50%.
But then the third flip, it
looks like it was tails again
because now only one out of
three or 33% of the flips
have resulted in heads.
Now by the fourth flip,
we got a heads again,
getting us back to 50th percentile.
Now the fifth flip, it looks
like we got another heads
and so now have three out
of five or 60% being heads.
And so, the general takeaway
here is when you have
one, two, three, four,
five, or six experiments,
it's completely plausible that
your experimental proportion,
your experimental probability diverges
from the real probability.
And this even continues
all the way until we get to
our ninth or tenth tosses.
But what happens if we do way more tosses.
So now I'm gonna do another,
well let's just do another 200
tosses and see what happens.
So I'm just gonna keep tossing here
and you can see, wow look
at this, there is a big run
getting a lot of heads right over here,
and then it looks like
there's actually a run of
getting a bunch of tails right over here,
then a little run of heads, tails,
and then another run of heads and notice,
even after 215 tosses, our
experimental probability
has still, is still reasonably different
than our theoretical probability.
So let's do another 200 and see
if we can converge these over time.
And what we're seeing in real-time here
should be The Law of Large Numbers.
As our number of tosses get
larger and larger and larger,
the probability that these
two are very different
goes down and down and down.
Yes, you will get moments
where you could even get
10 heads in a row or
even 20 heads in a row,
but over time, those will
be balanced by the times
where you're getting
disproportionate number of tails.
So I'm just gonna keep going, we're now at
almost 800 tosses.
And you see now we are converging.
Now this is, we're gonna
cross 1,000 tosses soon.
And you can see that our
proportion here is now 51%,
it's getting close now, we're at 50.6%.
And I could just keep
tossing, this is 1100,
we're gonna approach 1200 or
1300 flips right over here.
But as you can see, as we get
many many many more flips,
it was actually valuable to
see even after 200 flips,
that there was a difference
in the proportion
between what we got from the experiment,
and what you would theoretically expect.
But as we get to many many more flips,
now we're at 1,210, we're
getting pretty close
to 50% of them turning out heads.
But we could keep tossing
it more and more and more
and what we'll see is, as we get
larger and larger and larger, it is likely
that we're gonna get closer
and closer and closer
to 50%.
It's not to say that it's
impossible that we diverge again,
but the likelihood of
diverging gets lower and lower
and lower the more tosses,
the more experiments you make.